this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 26th of january the
joint is brought to you by zip recruiter
like i said 2022 is going to be a big
year for you and for a lot of businesses
but some industries are projected to
grow even more this year like pet
services everyone adopted a new pet last
year now somebody needs to train fido if
you own a business in one of these
industries you probably need to hire
asap there's only one place to go and
that place is ziprecruiter.com
put a slash in and joey and right now
you can try it for free that's right
it's wednesday and you're getting
something on the on for free jack you
could easily review
recommended candidates and invite them
to to your top choices to apply for your
job zip recruiters technology is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
candidate within the first day that's
how good they are but listen talk is
cheap now you can try ziprecruiter for
free
just go to
slash ziprecruiter.com
that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion providing quality cbd from the
gummies
to the tincture to the capsules cbd lion
has your back go to cbdline.com right
now read the third party lab results and
how it can work for you
if you find something
check out at the box press and joey
joint or church and get 20 off delivered
right to your house that's c
b
d
lion the joint is also brought to you by
oh my god
draftkings right here from [__]
jersey there's four teams remaining in
the nfl this weekend that's it
and you can bet them at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nfl your countdown to
super bowl 56 lawrence taylor's own
number new customers can get 56
to one odds this weekend on any team
just bet five dollars and get 280 in
free bets if your team wins that's a
score right there
now if you're not a new customer listen
to me draftkings and uncle joey got your
back you can experience the conference
championships with the same game parlays
[__] tremendous combine multiple bets
from the same game for a bigger payout
the more legs you add the more money you
can win how do you like that from your
uncle joey on a wednesday morning this
weekend you got san francisco at the
rams i think
and you also got kansas city playing
cincinnati this is
[__] fun-filled if you watch the game
last weekend they're not [__] around
now draftkings is safe secure and
reliable and you can get your deposit
and withdraw your cash whenever you want
so let's get this party started tonight
download the draftkings sportsbook app
now use promo code joey and get 56 to 1
odds on any nfl team this weekend
benches finals and win 280 and free bets
when your team wins that's promo code
joey j-o-e-y
and get 56 to one odds at draftkings
sportsbook the official sport betting
parlor
of the nfl
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana new york pa colorado new
customers applied minimum five hour
deposit and a dollar wager required
who's better than you nobody one per
customer restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com sportbook for details if
you got a gambling problem take care of
it call 1-800 gambler but if not
this weekend is your [__]
oyster let's make it happen download the
draftking sportsbook app use code joey
let's get this [__] party
started jack
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad eagle looking
[__] it's wednesday january 26
a beautiful [__] day here on
the plantation
we're trying to make it happen people
want to bother me when i'm starting
this beautiful [__] episode of the
joint
i'm feeling good i'm feeling better
i just smoked a little before the
podcast to loosen up a little bit get
the speedy those milos out of here i
didn't know if i told you yet we're back
monday but i'm also back mentally on the
[__] if you ain't high by two o'clock
go [__] your mother it's back in full
[__] swing i've been doing it for 30
days now so that puts me back in the
club and back as the ceo if you don't if
you're not high by 2 o'clock i don't
know what to do with yourself you know
what i'm saying me i'm happy again
because i get to smoke a little roots
and walk on the [__] treadmill
speaking of the treadmill i was on that
[__] this morning doing my
little joint
listening to power rage again i've been
going through every day i put in a
different album like yesterday was
[__] pyromania the day before
saturday was high and dry
[__] friday was no friday i didn't
walk yes i did i walked at night i put a
little black sabbath greatest hits i'm
always mixing it [__] up on the
treadmill but listen like i told you
[__] the treadmill got a lot
easier
when i do three [__] bong hits
i don't even put visine in my eyes i go
out there raw dogging it you know what
i'm saying it's in the it's early in the
morning i ain't gonna bump into no
parents i ain't gonna bump into normally
i'm gonna bump into the [__] relics
at the gym and they know i like to
[__] smoke some reef from time to
time but besides that it's been a great
[__] week so far before the
podcast started my shoulder popped out
so if i make funny faces like i got to
take a [__] it's got nothing to do with
that my [__] shoulder popped out me
and mike wildside hitting the the
[__] blunt of death he had one of his
[__] cocoa blunts
and i had a regular blunt from the dudes
and
we took a couple of hits nice
nice it's gonna snow
it was supposed to snow yesterday it
came down for a [__] maybe eight
[__] minutes i was excited too i'm
like [__] some snow people gonna be
off the streets my daughter's at school
that means when she gets home at [__]
four or three we gotta have a little
snowball fight kaputz and turn into
[__] water i don't know about this
climate [__] all i know is
that when i was growing up in jersey you
didn't see the sidewalk from [__]
december to like march and then you
started seeing like yellow snow the
first snow
that the dogs pissed on you see those
little frozen shits and then you see
like 22 inches of snow on top of that
that's the [__] jersey i grew up in
people calling me every day joey how
cold is it i mean it's 37
it was 15 last week that was cold but
besides that guys i grew up in this
[__] state when january was zero
zero like i've been thinking oh my god i
was thinking about my [__] past
january's here like it
like i did three things but i still
remember
the cold [__] weather like i could
still remember
pretty much what i wore to combat the
weather
like the coldest night i think i ever
encountered as a young kid i had a lot
of cold nights
but in january like i remember when
i had to cut through a cemetery one
night and it was freezing i had to pee
and my pee froze and my pants because i
took a [__] and i peed but i didn't pull
my pants all the way down and the pea
froze in my pants and then i remember
another night
when we were up at hudson county park
that was one of the coldest nights i
ever [__] encountered i had a stop
like every two blocks to duck in to get
warm people were throwing this out i
wasn't even giving a [__] i was just
going into business with my buddy lubes
we're like [__] it that's the night we
went to
the wing fung
on 78th and bergen line that was one of
the last times i ran out of that
[__] because we would go in
there and rob from them like not rob
physically but we go in there and get
like three entrees soups and [__] and
then we'd run the [__] out of there we
must have done that 20 times
i think by 80 81 they got used to us so
now they would [__]
lock the doors and [__] and it was just
bori i got bored with them chasing me
but one night we were in there
and then there was another night tonight
i went to see missing persons
in passaic
there's a [__] pretty good venue in
passaic i only went to passaic two times
just that theater early on before i knew
who the [__] they were
i went to see rainbow
and the [__] scorpions
and i knew michael shankly was there
i went with this [__] dude that was a
big he was into that type of music and
he had the ticket
but
the night i went there with fernie
bassasudo and my man beniri
we froze to death and we had a [__]
car he had a car and we were freezing
with the heater on that's how [__]
cold jersey was that's what i [__]
remember about jersey and on the corners
the puddle in the daytime the sun would
melt a little bit of the [__] snow
so the quarters the corners excuse me
would just be draining
uh like little melted [__] things but
if it got like after about by lunchtime
the drain would start to fill in and you
wouldn't know it you'd be walking down
the street concentrating on staying warm
and [__] minding your own business and
you stepped off the [__] sidewalk and
your whole foot went into that because
you thought it looked like ice it was it
would freeze
every 30 seconds the [__] would
freeze
you could step on it keep going and go
[__] i can't believe i went through the
ice your foot would be you would have to
wear even the galoshes it went through i
mean i was a goulash man i didn't like
winter boots and [__]
yeah i was a goulash man growing up
those galoshes like 10 [__] bucks you
strap them on your shoes over your boots
and they don't let you slip if i was a
goulash man
so i could tell you those galoshes are
good if you're not going to go deep sea
[__] fish diving if your foot goes to
the ice the galactic do no good your
whole [__] foot gets wet and all
sudden you're walking home and you hear
like
and after about another mile that
[__] foot freezes the [__] up dog
that's what i think that's what inspired
my fungi toenail that i got [__]
frosted all the way to the end when i
was a kid i remember those [__]
nights i just
there was a the prosaic theater
there was the night with focaracio then
there was another night i can't remember
it doesn't [__] oh it was the same
night then i ate the quaalude with folk
and those guys i couldn't make it home i
had to sleep in a [__] alleyway until
this day i got to ask myself how the
[__] i stayed warm in that [__]
all night because when i woke up i
couldn't move parts of my [__] body i
think it was the quaalude that stopped
my what's that [__] when your bones
freeze
outside if you don't have [__]
weather if you don't have like gloves on
and you keep throwing what's it called
yeah frostbite if you have frostbite for
a few minutes the [__] finger falls
off or whatever the [__] happens
dawg i slept on this frigid [__]
all night i had igloos around me
that was about the time
whenever i think about this dog listen
guys
i was a [__] young man i
i have no regrets i i will always tell
you this because i don't want you to
think like i was a
phi beta kappa when you look at the
pictures i posted a few weeks ago my
shoulders are big and you know i look
good and stuff but i was a [__]
complete [__]
and i'll never forget like 80 81
i think i told this story on the joe
rogan podcast and people hated me for
this
i had gotten some dough that was when i
[__]
cast the checks i cast these three
checks
i ended up making like 20 grand i was in
high school when i put the 20 grand in
my draw
under my socks and [__] nobody ever knew
that money was there
my friends would come over i was living
with the bend there's nobody and i would
just take the 20 off the top every night
like it was like my own atm machine i
don't know how long it lasted
it don't [__] matter but
i was a big shot the first week i got
the money right and some guy came up to
me and some girl had a crush on me
so i met him one night we bought like an
eight pack of beer each and we got some
weed
and we went behind this [__] fire
department on kennedy boulevard
up the block from roses that now defunk
rose's deli my heart goes out to tony
i love that [__] place i went there
like five times last year you know i
couldn't go up there a lot to north
bergen but
he closed and uh you know first it was
hash ways
and now it was tony's you know uh rose's
deli on rip on county boulevard i don't
know where my friends are gonna go now
that was one of my hangs too i go in
there get a quick ham and cheese they
got a tremendous roast beef with mac
with a mat with wet mutts and gravy that
would make your [__] [__] hairs
curl the [__] up but i took it to that
fire department left the block from
roses
and we just went behind there and we
were swapping spit we were drinking our
beers it was cold but when you got a
heart on it don't matter you know what
i'm saying when you when you're 18 17
and your dick is hard i could be nude
and they could i could be one of those
moks at the green bay game out there
yelling and [__] freezing their asses
off
i don't know how those [__] do
it up in green bay and then to drive
home with that green bay shirt after
they lost whoo
that's a tough [__] my heart
goes out to green bay and it's fans i
don't know where aaron rodgers
is gonna end up who gives a [__] we got
football this weekend [__] that's
all that matters listen you know me i
love my little draftkings [__] i love
doing my stuff on there
but i'm just sticking to football you
know what for a couple weeks day i was
playing basketball during the week and
stuff like that 25 bucks i would bet it
over so i'm like you know what it took
away from me during the week i didn't
like it i'd always be [__] uh
watching the computer or i'd have to
stop to see what the score i'm not one
of those guys that'll watch the whole
[__] game
but i would stop to you know like i'd be
watching or why my wife hold on there's
three minutes left let me watch the last
i don't need that so i'm just football
only which means i got these
this week and then the [__]
super bowl i ain't betting the pro bowl
that's what suckers there's a lot of
other [__] you can bet on anyway so we
went there we hit it off that night we
drank the eight pack we swapped some
spit i think she gave me a little bit of
titty you know i was impressed wow
so we're like listen i'm gonna walk you
home but we're definitely gonna meet
tomorrow night i was like that night i
only took like 40 dollars out i was
bringing the whole roll out we were
going for broke
we even did a couple bumps she liked the
bumps uh the guy she was dating the
reason why we sneaked that first
date and we were gonna and we snuck
after that for about i don't know we did
like maybe four months
the reason why we did everything on the
down-low because she had broken up with
her boyfriend in like five years he
started dating when she was like dad you
know what those relationships and
they're [__] like 11 and a half and
[__] like that and now she was like 17.
i had to be like either 17 or 18 81 yeah
i was 18 [__] years old
and i walked into a home i was a
complete gentleman but dog i was a
gentleman with [__] desires
you know what i'm saying that's a
different type of gentleman you know at
least i'm honest enough to admit it
ladies if you listen to this when you
bump into these guys and the gentleman
yeah that gentleman they open up the
door
you know they they want your grandmother
to come to the movie theater all that
[__] but guess what
they got desires
and if your grandmother does come to the
movie theater i want you to know
you're gonna have to pay for that lady
you have to lick a nut when you don't
want it on a plane because we're gonna
use it against you what about the time i
took your grandmother to the [__]
movies come on sniff my nut right here
on the plane i put you under the blanket
nobody knows nothing i'm saying just put
your mask on make sure your mask is on
so you don't get thrown off the plane
and uh you got your little that dog it's
i don't i don't know what's going on
anymore i just know i'm happy and i'm
having a good time with you
[__] on a beautiful wednesday
morning the attitude is back
i'm feeling better
so the next night
i go home i drop my girl hand off that
was her name and
i dropped her off she lived like on 80
[__] third street or something i had
a walk home in the cold i don't know if
i took a bus i don't remember doesn't
[__] matter joey
so the next morning i woke up dog you
know when you wake up when you're 18 you
got that dick of death
you can jerk off twice and nothing
happens you don't even break a sweat
and you take a shower and all day long
you're thinking about what you're gonna
do to some girl that night it's it's
ladies i need for you to understand this
that this is us
we don't sit there going i wonder if i
should give her a dozen flowers or 24
flowers no we're deciding whether we're
going to suck your ass first your [__]
tie you up you know we're trying to
[__] look at our bedroom and remember
we also like to think about what we
didn't do to you the first two dates
because a lot of times you go on your
first date with a chick you start
[__] dry humping you get to eat some
ass and [__] on the way home you got
i forgot to tie her wrist up i'll do it
on the second date you know i'm saying
so you always go back to improve but i
had never been without the time i could
lie to you guys and tell you i was
slinging dick like a man i wasn't
slinging no dick
so anytime [__] presented itself
i would go [__] bananas like any
other young [__] guy does right so
the next day dog i kept thinking about
this chick's
skinny body and i was gonna suck at
titties and nothing was gonna happen she
was a catholic [__] girl i was lucky
i kissed her neck that night and kissed
the titty
i think she [__] cried when i sucked
the titty i was i was in no danger half
of us weren't and now you come to full
realization how much of a [__] idiot
we were at that age so the next day i
wake up early in the morning dick hard
ready to go and i look at the [__]
window and there's got to be
you know 8 to 12 inches of snow
you know my [__]
heart broke but my dick stayed harder
than [__] mathematics jack
what did i do i didn't give up you think
i was going to give up ba
ba if you think i'm going to give up
i took that shovel and i walked all the
way to 85th street from the bender's
house i don't know whose shovel i
borrowed i don't give a [__] i think i
even brought on the bus with me i don't
give a [__] jack i brought that [__]
thing up there and i [__] dug it out
guys
i still remember one of the firemen
coming out and going what are you doing
kid i'm like no no i'm volunteering i
wasn't [__] volunteering i was
building so when he caught me i had to
do like a pathway
so it was perfect like nobody walked
back there there was nothing going on
behind the firehouse nobody even knew it
[__] existed there was a little spot
back there i [__]
shoveled it out
you know it's freezing out i'm shoveling
out there i don't know if it was january
february december i i don't [__] know
i'm out there [__] doing my thing and
the next thing you know
i'm looking around like and i see like a
little carpeting
dog
like a rip carpeting remember when
[__] uh
paulie and christopher was stuck in the
pine barrens in the van and they found
the carpet in the back and they ripped
it in half and dust and fingernails and
toe jam and [__] juice and crabs and
anything else that could live in a
carpet was in that carpet i did not give
a [__]
i took that carpet i beat it against the
wall a couple times i shook a bunch of
stuff out and i'm like maybe
i'll put a little like a an igloo
together guys i built like a [__]
foot little thing
to keep us warm and i put the
carpet on the bottom and i think i there
was some kind of fencing and i put like
an old blanket back there to block the
wind i had in my mind
and you're [__] perverted disgusting
hard on when you're 18 year old mind i
thought i was doing the right thing now
listen if i was [__] any smart i
should have gave one of my older friends
some cash and just took it to a hotel i
had the [__] money there was tons of
hotels on [__] tunnel avenue
tons of them those little dirty hotels
where even if you don't have a date
you'll end up with a date
those hotels on tunneling avenue on
route one and nine there from north
bergen all the way down to jimmy city
whatever's left
if you don't have a date just check into
there somebody will knock on your door i
don't know if it's gonna be the woman of
your dreams
but somebody will knock on your door
so instead of doing that
i was all excited
and i [__] built the [__] little
lovely glue out there
and i went to the liquor store i brought
beers already to try to impress her like
ha ha
i have beers because any time you're on
a date your first joint before you get
if you think getting a pants is going to
be hard that's one thing but [__]
going to get somebody to get liquor for
you that was another
so i had people that would always get
your liquor but when i was going to get
liquor people would tag on and then it
would go from one eight pack or a bottle
of [__] boons boom booms farm to
eight cases of beer so i didn't want
that to happen
so i went there in the daytime got my
little [__] eight pack got another
like a bottle i don't even know it
wasn't beer that she was drinking i do
remember that i don't know what i got
and i don't want to stick my foot in my
mouth i don't know if it was boone's
farm or whatever
but i hit it all out there i put some
[__] snow on it like johnny romantico
and i [__] went home i took a shower
i cut my toenails i put cologne on the
whole [__] uncle joey packaged when
he's 18.
and i walked up there for her to tell me
that she wasn't allowed out that night
and that was the adventures of joey's
love igloo if i was smart i would have
gone to the igloo done a grandma blow
and bang one out by myself and came on
the carpet what little [__] young kids
do but i don't i don't even know what i
did but those
are my adventures
in the cold [__] hairs of new
jersey so i know all about the weather
here i see all these people i see the
little [__] ugly girl with the red
hair
yelling about the climate i don't know
greta whatever greta van stone i don't
[__] know what his name is
and i'm here to tell you that the
weather has [__] changed
a lot
in new jersey it's not that [__]
human in the summer like i remember and
i remember it hate in the [__] summer
this i did great a little bit of
humidity you know
like jay-z you know i'm saying swipe
your [__] bug off your chest there
but i don't remember like a bad summer
and this winter so far guys you know
people bust my balls all the time
you were in california you [__] idiot
it's 75 degrees here you know what
that's great i lived in that weather for
a long time and i lived in the colorado
climate for a long time which is 12 to
13 [__] years
i've lived in it i've been there done
that i was ready for this and i got to
be honest with you
it's not that bad
i'll tell you [__] monday night it
was cold as a [__] out i
remember no i think it was monday night
sunday night the night of the games
my daughter and my wife were at a
friend's house with a like a
a [__]
when the kids get together on a play
date
it had to be like six o'clock there was
dinner upstairs
but i was like i already had [__]
salisbury steak
you know it was really [__] good she
made it with some mushrooms and onions
my wife hit it out of the park but i
didn't i didn't think i wanted to eat
salads berry steak again
but i gotta [__] be honest with you
it wasn't bad so i said you know what
maybe i was in the mood maybe like uh
get like i don't know a pizza or
something i don't know something
completely different
guys
i opened up my door and i felt that gust
of wind and i said you know what
i'm gonna eat that salisbury steak
because this other [__] it's too [__]
cold out
i had a sweatshirt on i had my jacket i
just didn't feel like warming up the
[__] car that still sucks
when you get up in the morning but i got
it down to a sciences i lived in
colorado i didn't have it to a science
here because well i didn't have a car
what was it going to warm up my bus i
didn't have a [__] nothing then
so here you know i just go out there
start the car
put the defrost on
the subaru has
seats that warm up tremendous your
asshole's on fire you keep your
hemorrhoid nice and warm but can i do
something 15 minutes
i go out there
that i haven't [__] taken the snow
off my window
i don't know how long it's not like
colorado snow so i just sit in the car
and
go for a [__] ride that's it when the
car gets nice and warm i'm [__] gone
no drama done the other thing i wanted
to talk about today i want to talk to
you guys about something that
i don't know if it's always been like
this
or
if this just started during the pandemic
i know that there was a lot of change
when covert hit you know social
a lot of social consciousness and all
this stuff you know whether it was good
or bad that's got nothing to do with me
you know everybody adjusted to whatever
they could and they played the game for
the best they can
you know it's great to see two football
players punching each other and the one
guy's helmet says inspire change on it
you know what i'm saying so
it's [__] tough to to digest think
guys i'm an old-school type guy and i
see things for what they are
there's some things that could change
there's some things you can educate
people on
but people are who the [__] they are you
know so
but for some reason or another the last
i've noticed this a lot and a lot of
people not going to be happy with this
conversation and i really don't give a
[__] because
what do i got to lose at this point in
the game you know
i've always liked neil young
you know i've always liked [__] neil
young okay
i went to see uh
a movie when i was a kid you know neil
young the other two [__] moose and i
just really like their harmonizing you
know crosby stills nash and young
two or three mooks
crosby still smashing young three i'm
sorry
four whatever the [__] so
i've always dug his music and stuff
i watched that movie
at the fairview cinema you know
close to 40 [__] years ago
and uh
i really enjoyed neil young i don't know
and i
had the album you know which i'm trying
to get now because i really [__] like
it a lot russ never sleeps
so uh
i like that hour my light and that was a
big summer for me it was like summer of
74.
a summer
or 76 who the [__] knows
uh
i just like neil young i like his music
i like you know i'm goofing on years now
with crosby stills nash and young i like
all that music i like ohio i you know i
like john fogerty i like that time
period i was really [__] impressed
when i saw that neil young was friends
with rick james in canada in the 60s and
they both had
the same type of views and stuff about
the war you know whatever
but
[__] neil young always has to [__]
raise his hand you guys are too young to
remember this [__] i think i mentioned
it on the podcast
sorry about my shoulders [__] killing
me for some reason uh
i don't know maybe 1987 before i got
locked up
you know i was a fan of everybody i
wasn't really involved in music like i
was
when i was younger before i got locked
up you know i was
buck wild i think it was the year that
def leppard released pour some sugar on
me and
you two released uh whatever that really
good album about
the orchid tree or whatever
whatever the [__] it is so
you know
i was into music but i wasn't like i was
when i was
82 81 those years 70 79 80.
but i still remember like i liked them
tv and [__] i was watching them tv news
one time
and they were talking about neil young
attacked
the other crazy man
eric clapton i don't know what the [__]
that [__] is smoking
that guy got hit in the head with a
[__] guitar they you know it's time
for somebody to go talk to [__] eric
clapton you know what i'm saying you
ever see the movie irishman like they
kept saying somebody's got to go over
talk to the hopper
it's time to talk to [__] eric
clapton i mean
yeah you know what anybody got cheryl
crow's number because i guarantee she
could get through to harry clapton you
know what i'm saying like somebody's got
to get through to eric clapton i
appreciate that [__] you guys
know i'm a fan of his until the end
you know the racist things it was in 73
people feel differently now than they
did then he was on heroin he made
mistakes i forgive them you know he said
some [__] crude [__] up on stage you
know
doesn't really [__] matter i respect
his guitar playing
and i respect him you know he [__]
built that place
for junkies he sold all his guitars
to fund the place to help recovering
heroin addicts he's done a lot of good
things so
before you [__] you know a lot of
times i gotta say this because four
weeks from now i talk to a friend of
mine
or i'll get an email from a friend a
different somebody who listens to the
show and goes i didn't like
when you stuck up for that guy or put
him down i'll tell you the reasons why i
don't like him but i also tell you the
reason why i respect these guys i
respect the [__] out eric clapton first
time i saw [__] eric clapton was
jumping up and down and tommy
with uh the who when they do
eyesight to the blind and i knew i loved
that [__] and i knew his music i
just didn't know him you know
it's just a lot of [__] that do
no wrong around me and i love them and
i'm a fans of them
but and i've met eric clapton i've met
him at clapton i saw him at a comedy
show one time
i said hello to him and then i saw him
on lebron boulevard walking he was
parked in the car and i waved and he
smiled at me
dawg i love [__] eric clapton but
this [__] the last three years listen
whether he's right or wrong it's just
that he's too old to be arguing with
these [__] anymore
like he's just too old eric
you know first you're not going to play
when he wrote the vaccine song or
whatever the [__] the antibiotic song or
the covet song i'm like oh
don't start with this [__] but then he
started making [__] crazy statements
yesterday and you know what guys
sometimes for these older guys
i think that
you know how it sucks when you haven't
put on an arm for 10 years
it must suck
i haven't put on a special since 2018
and it sucks you know
an artist has to stay active and
do the best he can you know every couple
years to put something out when you
don't put something out for 10 years
that's it you know you're going into a
different uh
realm of your life but at the same time
things are changing around no more but
your phone ain't ringing like it used to
you lost a bunch of friends those people
who thought you were [__] brilliant
you know
i don't even talk to you anymore
you know so
what do you do
you [__] sit at home and now you look
at
the success that influencers have and
joe rogan has and all these people and
you go well maybe i'll open up my mouth
and
they do and they get [__]
bashed over the head right away i don't
know what happened with eric he wasn't
gonna perform in covert places that he
was going to perform with him it's been
a [__] meltdown over there eric baby
you're [__] killing me i love you i'm
here i got your back [__] sucker
and then you got neil young you know who
owns lionel i think doesn't he own a
train company a choo-choo company and
you know he's got so much going on he's
[__] daryl hannah and that old dry
[__] i think he's banging daryl and i
don't [__] know doesn't really make a
difference i shouldn't be saying these
things
but you know he comes out
you know and you know why he's doing it
the article explained it to you that
spotify play pays who gots he has
nothing to lose by doing that by
threatening them i'm getting out of here
unless joe logan's thrown off the
platform you know
you know people just
[Music]
people are just like you know it's some
call upon you know all this [__]
the way people are attacking
brogan and
dr malone i mean that dude they're
throwing eggs at his house and [__] and
you know what man at the end of the day
when you think about it this [__] is all
misleading [__] information
it's all misleading information you
haven't gotten good information since
day one about this [__] [__] at this
point just move on with your life do the
best you [__] can take your vitamins
jump up and down eat your wife's [__]
and do the best you [__] can move
forward you're gonna if they don't want
you to go to work you move we work
around this [__] but to sit there and
every [__] day
they try to bombard that's why you got
to get the [__] out you got to live your
life i'm very happy i got it in december
it lifted a [__] tremendous weight
off my [__] shoulders it you know it
didn't prove anything to me it just
proved to me that i could live and i
feel happy about it but at the same time
these [__] lunatics are like losing
their [__] minds in an old age
neil young got more money than any of
you [__] know what to do it
we all say if i haven't had neil young
money yet do it then
neil young go and listen to 10 people go
to your ten of your fans and go what
would you do if you had 50 million
dollars
and you were these guys are selling
their [__] things now
their whole [__] catalogs i think
neil young did it too neil young
dylan did it i mean they're all doing it
the motley crue did it molly cruz
complete with mack got some loot but
motley crue got like a buck
a buck uh i don't even think motley crue
got a lot of money
money crew got a million
125 million maybe something like that
but you got divided by four [__] guys
so
at the end of the week you're like what
the [__] what was it i guarantee they're
all busy doing heroin or whatever and
not everybody wrote the same amount so
it all works out to [__] watch nikki
six
but
i'm talking about this near young guy
and this isn't where i'm going with this
either but we joked around we had a good
time you know i'm trying to break it
down for you guys but think about it for
somebody to call up and going less
you get rid of this guy
i'm taking my music now let me tell you
something i know neil's intelligent i
hope so i hope that dementia and nobody
hit him in the head with a guitar or you
know crosby and stills aren't sending
[__]
hate mail to him i don't know what's
going on with neil
so what if
spotify doesn't answer them
and
they keep broken on i mean listen
276 doc you know
everybody is trying to get this kid off
the thing you know rogan's trying his
best
i like what he's doing he makes me he
makes me laugh because of the reaction
he's getting
people are like him and if you read the
re i love
when white people are
blasting what's that word they say i'm
i'm flabbergasted now people are roaring
with anger
you know i see people all day long
ain't nobody roaring with [__] anger
around me you know like
the statements he makes now i don't
listen to all of joe's podcast i don't
you know i'm busy i'm doing [__] i get
the realm i talk to my friends who
listen i i speak to joe from time to
time he breaks it down for me we giggle
and we laugh because it's like
at the end of the [__] week it's
comedians talking
nobody has put that together yet
that if you really take seriously what a
comedian says you're out of your mind
but to bet it
to better phrase this
you know man when did we
become bigger than
what's going on
when did we become bigger than what's
going on and i'm just listen
i love neil and whatever but he's out of
his [__] mind he already knows the
answer
that if it's between him and rogan
they're gonna
tell neil to go [__] himself
and i know he's got a new album coming
out woo you know ain't nobody waiting
for that [__]
so no no disrespect neil but you know
everybody wants to [__] listen to
tick-tock music and [__] you know unless
you're killing people at a concert hey
nobody buying your music you know what
i'm saying
so
but the thing that kills me the most
about this is that all of a sudden
people could dominate a platform people
could
you know it started a few years ago with
rogan you know maybe a year ago i'm
sorry a year and a half ago
when the lgbtq people that worked there
were threatening to quit
or friends and families of
lgbtq people were threatening to quit
now this is just logic i'm not trying to
be an [__] but think about it
you got a company
of a hundred people
and
you've got after all these years of
busting your hump you know yeah you got
little [__] people on there you got
joey diaz and ari doing podcasts nobody
gives a [__] about them
the new white america the new kid from
18 to 34
is getting groomed on [__] rogan
and that's just the way it is
accept it you [__] maggots
it's just the way it is it's what's
happening
so for
now i i
you know i
i feel for these employees who are
sitting in an office
and
the guy that this company they're
working for is putting so much stock in
this [__]
you know guguts
you know and
it's kind of effective like it's gotta
go well
we're giving money to a guy that's
going off on people like me i i don't
know i don't know and that's fine now
let me ask you a question
we've all had day jobs we've all had
jobs we've all been putting on weird
situations
if you're in a job
and i don't know what they're making for
a living but i do know that you were
looking for a job
when you found that one i've been very
unhappy in my
life with jobs you know my [__]
career with jobs but at the same time
how long do you want to stay there and
take this if it really bothers you get
your [__]
get the other three guys in the office
all the three ladies in the office or
the he she's i don't know i'm not here
to offend anybody and let's get the [__]
out of here let's get a job at a
restaurant who appreciates us
who will
put us in a safe haven
are you guys with me here
in a little safe haven where nobody's
going to offend you that's what i would
do but if you think i'm going to take
the three other employees or the seven
or six other employees beside myself and
march into the office of
mr netflix and say
you know uh mr spotify and go hey mr
spotify me and my six
friends here are very angered by the
comments joe rogan makes
and we're threatening to quit if you
don't throw them off your platform
well i appreciate your [__] set of
balls or whatever but
at the same time
are you [__] crazy are you [__]
[__]
this guy generates millions of dollars
and this is what i would tell them as mr
spotify like listen i don't like joey
diaz i don't like ari i don't like rogan
either
but this broken guy is paying the bills
so if you want to walk i understand you
want him to walk because you don't agree
with his views
but think about it i can't get rid of
him over what seven people are feeling
the numbers are not correct it's not
fair that you put me in that [__]
barrel
11 million people listen to our little
[__] friend in texas
but because your feelings get hurt
we got to get rid of them and i
understand but just i'm not putting
anybody down here i'm just saying
just you thinking that way that i'm
gonna march in there with my six friends
and i'll tell you what
i got news for you even if you march in
with your 100 friends
they're not gonna get rid of joe rogan
i'm sorry to hear that you know
um
i don't want to say this because i don't
want to ruin mike's watching the wire
and a lot of you [__] are
watching the wire so i can't even use
this as a reference
but i use this as a reference for me
when
and here this is different so you've got
seven employees that are not happy
correct you got seven employees that are
not happy or eleven employees that are
not happy and you come to me and i have
100 employees maybe 150 employees
your percentage is is [__] nothing
and again no offense to nobody i'm just
talking to you from two perspectives
here before you go out and [__] say
well me and my three friends are leaving
because joe diaz says [__] um whatever
well let me tell you something
you know in this case this is the same
thing you're not bigger than what's
going on
for you to come into my office whether
you're neil young whether you're [__]
the guys at spotify or the herds of
spotify and the guys at netflix or the
hers at netflix and come into my office
and threaten me with your job over dave
chappelle or joe rogan or whoever the
[__] you're completely out of line
like if you really think about what's
going on you know i love the gay
community i [__] love them i had a
great relationship with my friends in
california i spoke to them i have no gay
friends here i don't know what the [__]
is wrong with jersey but in california i
was there for 23 years i had my neighbor
i had eric who i loved i talked spoke to
him the other day i would love to get
him on the podcast again but he's doing
great things he headlined the madhouse
he's headlining but you know we work
different schedules i got to have him on
the daytime so it's been kind of rough
with that but
what you're trying to tell me is that
you don't wanna
you know with the gay community that was
i saw some problems every once in a
while i saw problems on sets
which i never really discussed because i
kept them to the set
but at times
they thought that them being gay
was bigger than what's going on
you know you guys know what movie i
worked on that had
tremendous masculinity i don't have to
utter the words
and when i worked on that set there was
a
a young
gay dude that i [__] loved to death
he was one of the high ups there
you know he was having a problem with
this masculinity
he wasn't uh a flamboyant gay guy
like i i knew him for like maybe six
weeks before he told me he was gay
it was just him and i talking in the
[__] in my trailer about weed or
whatever the [__] we're talking about
i think when we went back to
california
he had to work closer with all of us
you know at first he was kind of working
with me and maybe lobo and [__] nick
and
you know in fact me and nick still goof
around about that guy that guy used to
wear
pink no
oh my god so when it got out that he was
gay you know again nobody busted his
balls or anything we all dug him to
death
he was upset about
the cop talk
the [__] in the ass talk even though
that's the whole thing of being gay is
jumping up and down and [__] people
in the ass and going to parties
he had a problem with the talk and i got
it he was outnumbered on that set
do you know what this guy did
like week 11
he found another job
we stayed in touch for maybe a year he
ended up going to premiere it was a
bunch of love
nobody really knew this he came to me
and i think nicki was just talking he
goes i just don't want to be around here
no more one of those shoes that people
wear now with the holes in them they're
rubber
gators or whatever the [__] people wear
the crocs crocs
dog they gave him a pair of pink rocks
uh one of the linebackers the bad the
bad [__] from
the raiders at the time like just his
his name switched my mind but they gave
him
pink rocks and he [__] wore him and i
loved the guy and guess what everybody
on the set loved him
it wasn't even there was no gay hate
nothing like that
the extreme you know suck my [__] and
[__] you and uh and [__] hitting each
other with eggs he wasn't from that cut
and i
that dog i'm not from a lot of cuts so i
understood he quit and i never had
nothing against him he quit on his own
he didn't complain
to anybody didn't go to the producers
and try to get anybody fired he had a
job to do he knew he was outnumbered
he knew he was outnumbered so
i don't understand how
anybody right now like
in the trans community again my deepest
apologies but
you can't go against what's bigger than
you right now and i get it
you're doing great things you're very
proud of what you're doing and i'm proud
of you for you listen sometimes i sit
there i go you know how proud i am of
guys that come out like you know in
california how many guys i knew
dug i could count on my hands that were
[__] gay and living in a [__]
secret
that's gotta suck dick i know it sucked
dick when i was doing coke and i didn't
want nobody to know imagine taking in
the ass and going to parties and having
come on your feet and [__] i was talking
to a gay friend of mine from la and he
did tell me i think i'd tell you this
that he has a guy that just comes over
rubs his feet and when he finishes he
whacks off on him that's hysterical i
would love to come
on somebody's feet not another men's
nine and a half size
[__] disgusting foot with hair on the
toes you know what i'm saying but i love
to come on a nice little
you're wise feet or something you know
anyway that's a long time i don't want
to come on nobody's feet no more i don't
even think comes comes out of my dick
anymore i think it's just like one
little drop or whatever the [__] it is i
don't even know i don't even i don't
even check what do i care i'm on to
bigger and better things
but
the whole thing here just bothers me
sometimes how you think
that you're bigger than what's going on
neil young i love you it's not your
fault you know we're just getting old
and [__] the people that spotify
how bad do you feel if you stand at
spotify and you're there now
you came to a reality that they don't
really [__] care about you
like they don't care you got to assume
that they don't [__] care
because when you think that they do care
that's when your feelings are going to
get hurt and that's when you're going to
feel like the system is breaking down
but it's not the system's not breaking
down there's nobody against you
the problem is that [__]
you're not bigger than the [__]
problem at hand
if you don't like what's going on around
you neil young
pull your [__] music off i can live
with that if i i put you on
facebook yesterday ohio i love that
[__] jam and i did that for a reason
to prove to you i'm a big fan but
you're too old who gives a [__] where
your music is just take it off spotify
it's already on your website really
re-release redone
what the [__] do you want i'm saying
give me a breather
the guys at spotify look what happened
they had a parade for you
uh for you guys him and hers you know
and
not a parade they had a press conference
you know you had cnn there and the media
and
it worked it tried but you know what
again my heart goes out to you but
you're not bigger than what's going on
don't ever think that just
be you be happy
go trans go
[__] do your thing don't worry about
what people think about you it's the
same thing
when i got into county i was a felon i
would tell people to be a comedian
yeah it hurt my feelings for a while
until i [__] committed to it
and then like [__] you you didn't have
my back so now i'm moving the [__] on
and for the employees that uh spotify
now with rogan or whatever
didn't you know
money
money beats everything money is the root
of all [__] evil and as much as it
hurts it hurts you know i know there's
times when i was with an agent and i
didn't like things that were going on
with another client was it jealousy
no i didn't like them but guess what
it's got nothing to do with me
all i need to do is get up in the
morning
take my vitamins bang one out do some
push-ups and go out there and be the
best that i can [__] be and that's it
and that's that
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive this wednesday the 26th i'm
excited the month is over next monday
that'll be our last podcast
for the month i got some surprises for
february i'm having a birthday in
february i'm doing a couple things in
february hari shafia is doing a
storytelling show
at the gramercy theater february 8th
get your tickets it's all [__] uh
you know no lineup that's the way i like
harry does it uh will i be there i'm not
sure i don't know i don't have a story
the only way i'll know is if i get up
that morning and that night at six
o'clock and i'm like i feel like going
to the gramercy theater so i'm not
making
any promises i'm just shedding some
light on the show i'm excited for ari
because he's going to start this over
again
under a new name and
that [__] uh
that story show
did more for me
than my [__]
netflix special it did more for me than
the other special
those things on comedy central [__]
leveled me man so
i'm forever grateful to hari
if i do grace the stage again
it'll probably be on one of those
storytelling things but i'm not sure
about the eighth he's gonna have it
every [__]
month but uh go to gramercy
park whatever the theater is
infogramercy.com whatever the [__] it is
google it and uh see what the rules are
i know you're gonna need a [__] uh
vaccine card and a mass so you know do
what you need to do i understand if you
can't go but hey if you could support
ari shafir
that would be [__] trimming be simo
also
as you guys could tell i found the
winning combination i had too much of a
stick up my ass when i moved back here
you know i was telling i think my wife
when i was eating
breakfast this morning i go you know i
was on the treadmill
and i was just that's why i like about
the treadmill i'm back to walk and and
back to thinking you know
and i'm thinking about good things it's
not you know how do i get out of this
gig in [__] ohio
it's about all good things i was
thinking about
where i really honestly was at this time
last year and i wish i could take you
guys there it's it wasn't
[__] pretty i found one of the old
that's why i was looking
at the youtube last week that's how i
knew they were putting 18 and under on
them
because i was going back to last january
to see my eyes and [__]
guys i was not in a good [__] place
at all after that surgery
between the [__]
pain pills the [__]
withdrawing from the xanax my anxiety i
couldn't even [__] think
i couldn't even uh
you know
focus on anything i couldn't even have
lunch with friends or anything i
couldn't wait for my friends to [__]
leave when they were around but
i'm happy i'm happy i identified what
was going on with me and i'm happy uh
that it all worked out and we're here a
year later but i'm really happy
that the people who stuck it out with me
[__] stuck it out with my people on
patreon i love you [__] with
all my heart i think i'm doing brenda's
zurigas podcast this week
and i think i'm doing another one with
secular in the next couple weeks i gotta
give him a call back
and that's my itinerary guys i'm happy
you guys checked in
to the joint on uh january 26
and i will see you [__] monday
tip topic do not forget this podcast was
brought to you by honet they produce all
my [__] podcasts i love on it
this week's special all supplements 20
[__] percent off use code joey i love
you stay black have a great weekend and
i'll see you [__] nice and
early tip top magoo monday morning love
you
all right i want to thank you guys
for listening to me [__] around about
neil young today i appreciate it but the
joint is brought to you by zip recruiter
like i said
it's going to be a big year for a lot of
businesses 2022.
and like the pet business is growing
there's a lot of businesses that are
growing
and now somebody needs to train fido
if you own a business in one of these
industries you probably need to hire
somebody asap you all do there's only
one place that got your answer zip
recruiter baby right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
joey again you can easily review
candidates and invite them your top
choices to apply for your job it's that
easy zip recruiters technology is so
effective that four out of five
employees who post on zipper go to
county candidate within the first day
you can't beat that
right now time is money and money is
time right now you can try ziprecruiter
for free
at this exclusive web app
ziprecruiter.com
joey again
that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire cbd lion always coming through for
you
from the [__] uh bat balls
which i need to jump in one of those my
shoulders killing me the cream i'll put
some on there after i get out of there
the capsules you eat one and you sleep
like a baby plus you got the tincture
that's tremendous you got the gummies
that are tremendous you got the
kinesiology tape and dra and uh
draftkings and cbd lion don't stop there
go to cbd lion
read the third party lab results leave
it read about cbd
cbn and cby and let's get this party
started press in joey joint church and
get 20 off delivered right to your
[__] house cbd lion the king
the joint is also brought to you by
listen draftkings let's make some money
this weekend last week you [__] around
with your friends and you ate onion dip
and you jumped up and down but did you
make any money all you did was wear your
[__] hat and walk around all week
just watch the game it's time to [__]
get down netflix
draftkings is giving you 56 to one odds
on any of the four teams this weekend
just bet 5 hours and get 280 if your
team wins it's that easy
you're not a new customer i don't know
what to tell you draftkings has your
back
you can experience the same game paul
a's combine multiple bets from the same
game for a bigger payout plus they got
some great
little side bets who's gonna score first
first field goal blah blah blah it all
adds up to money and fun
download the draftking sportsbook app
today the official
the official
sports betting partner to the nfl that's
promo code joey to get 56 to one odds
now you got to be 21 older new jersey
new york indiana pa
colorado west virginia new customers
only minimum final deposit and a dollar
wager required who's better than you one
per customer restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you've got
a gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler take care of yourself
but if not
head over to draftkings
download the app and let's win some
[__] money i want to thank
draftkings
zip recruiter liquid iv
cbd lion
and my people over there better help
helping people out check them out
if you're hearing voices of chinese
people singing to you
it was a great week i love you guys
thank you for welcoming us back and
we'll be back next weekend ready rock
monday tip
top magoo i love you [__] stay
black and healthy
you